♪ ♪
>> Tucker: THE CALIFORNIA
WRINKLES FINALLY HERE, IT IS
TOMORROW.
GAVIN NEWSOM IS THE GOVERNOR,
BUT THE PROBLEM HE'S A BAD
GOVERNOR AND THE STATE HAS
GOTTEN MUCH WORSE SINCE HE RUN
IT.
THEY WANT TO HOLD POWER AT ALL
COST BUT ENDORSING GAVIN NEWSOM
MEANS THEY HAVE TO PRETEND
CALIFORNIA IS OKAY WHICH IS TO
ISNOT.
HERE'S THE LATEST EXAMPLE.
IT CRYSTALLIZES IT.
WE ARE GOING TO PLAY THE GAME
WHICH COUNTRY IS THAT, BUT IT'S
NOT BRAZIL, IT'S MELROSE AVENUE
IN LOS ANGELES.
WATCH.
>> LOOK AT THAT, STORE
SURVEILLANCE VIDEO SHOWING TWO
MEN, ONE WITH A GUN, STEALING
PROPERTY FROM RESTAURANT
CUSTOMERS INCLUDING THE .
SOMETIMES IT'S BEEN ONE CRIME
AFTER ANOTHER, A ROBBERY ON JULN
AUGUST 11TH.
>> Tucker: I'M SORRY TO THE
VIEWERS FROM BRAZIL.
IF THAT AN INSULT TO BRAZIL.
THAT'S A CALIFORNIAN DREAM,
THAT'S WHAT DEMOCRATS ARE
DEFENDING.
LARRY ELDER IS TRYING TO CHANGE
IT AND RUNNING TO REPLACE GAVIN
NEWSOM.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON,
LARRY ELDER.
BASICALLY YOU'RE RUNNING THE
RECALL HAS FOR US TO
BARACK OBAMA, KAMALA HARRIS,
NANCY PELOSI, ALL OF THEM TO
ENDORSE THE INEXCUSABLE.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THEY HAVE CUT COMMERCIALS FOR
HIM, THEY HAVEN'T DEFENDED HIM
ON CRIME AS YOU DISPLAYED, THEY
HAVEN'T DEFENDED HIM ON THE RISE
OF COST-OF-LIVING, CALIFORNIA
WITH AN AVERAGE PRICE OF A HOME
AT $80,000.
IF THEY HAVE A DIFFERENT NAME ON
THE RISE OF HOMELESSNESS, THE
DECLINE OF THE QUALITY OF PUBLIC
SCHOOLS.
IF NOT DEFENDED THE WAY HE SHUT
DOWN TO THE POINT WHERE
ONE-THIRD OF BUSINESSES ARE GONE
AND MANY OWNED BY BLACK AND
BROWN AND ASIAN-AMERICAN PEOPLE
AND THE PEOPLE ON THE LEFT LIKE
GAVIN NEWSOM CLAIM TO CARE
ABOUT.
THEY HAVE NOT DEFENDED HIS WAY
OF MANAGING THE FOREST, HAVEN'T
DEFENDED HIM FOR FAILING TO ADD
ANY REAL WAY TO THE WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE.
CALIFORNIA HAS THE SAME WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE IT HAD 40 YEARS
AGO.
WE ARE HAVING ROLLING BROWNOUTS
BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T ADEQUATELY
MANAGE THE POWER GRADE.
IF THE POLITICIANS HAVE CUT
COMMERCIALS FOR HIM AND THEY'D
NEVER UTTERED THE FOLLOWING
MAGICAL WORDS.
GAVIN NEWSOM HAS DONE A GOOD JOB
FOR THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
>> Tucker: I DON'T UNDERSTAND
AND I'M SURE THERE'S A TON OF
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA WHO SAY I
DON'T AGREE WITH EVERYTHING THAT
LARRY ELDER SAID TO COME UP WITH
THERE'S PEOPLE WHO ARE LIVING
IT'S LIKE AL QAEDA BUT WORSE.
HOW CAN ANYBODY VOTE FOR THAT?
SINCERE QUESTION.
>> I DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT
EITHER.
63% OF THE HISPANICS VOTED FOR
THEM TWO EUROS OUT AND THE
MAJORITY WANT HIM ON.
MAJORITY OF INDEPENDENTS WANT
THEM OUT AND NOW THE MAJORITY
WANT AMOUNT.
CRIME DOESN'T HAVE A COLOR OR
PARTY.
THE CRIME OF PUBLIC EDUCATION
DOESN'T HAVE A PARTY.
IF I SUPPORT SCHOOL CHOICE, THE
NUMBER ONE TO OBSTACLE IS THE
SCHOOL CHOICE IS THE TEACHERS
UNION, NOT TEACHERS, TEACHERS
UNION.
GAVIN NEWSOM IS A POWERFUL
TEACHER UNIONS.
WHY THEY DO MY GIMMICK THAT
STOPS THEM FROM THE NUMBER ONE
PATH
path
I WANT TO BREAK THE JEDI MIND
TRICKS TRANQUIL DAY HAVE AND WHY
OBAMA AND BERNIE SANDERS, THEY
WEIGHED IN ON DAYS WHEN THEY
CAN'T DEFEND THE INDEFENSIBLE
RECORD OF MY OPPONENT GAVIN
NEWSOM.
>> Tucker: I'VE GOT TO SAY,
THEY'VE GONE AFTER YOU
PERSONALLY.
GAVIN NEWSOM HAS A GENERALLY
CREEPY PERSONAL LIFE I'M JUST
SAYING.
LOOK IT UP IF YOU WANT.
IT'S WEIRD.
I DON'T THINK YOU'RE ATTACKING
HIS LIFE OR HIS PERSONAL LIFE?
ARE YOU STICKING TO THE ISSUES
IT SEEMS LIKE TO ME?
>> I'M TRYING TO STICK TO THE
ISSUES BUT I WILL TELL YOU, I'VE
BEEN ATTACKED AS BEING A SEXIST
AND THE DAY BEFORE YESTERDAY
ROSE McGOWAN THE ACTRESS WHO
OUTED HARVEY WEINSTEIN SAID SIX
MONTHS BEFORE THE BIG REVEAL,
GAVIN NEWSOM'S WIFE CALLED HER
ON BEHALF OF HARVEY WEINSTEIN'S
LAWYER AND SAID SOMETHING TO THE
FACT OF WHAT CAN I DO TO MAKE
YOU HAPPY?
WHAT CAN I DO TO MAKE THIS THING
GO AWAY?
I DON'T IF IT'S TRUE OR FALSE
BUT IT'S BEEN ALLEGED AGAINST
ME, THAT'S ALL THEY BE TALKING
ABOUT UNTIL THEY DAY I DIE.
COMPLETELY OBLIVIOUS TO THE
STORY COME AS A BOMBSHELL STORY
AND IF IT'S MADE ME.
>> Tucker: SPEAKING OF ROSE
McGOWAN, SHE'S NOT ACTUALLY --
FUNNY YOU MENTION THAT, LARRY
ELDER, I APPRECIATE YOU COMING
ON.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING THE
BLACK FACE OF WHITE SUPREMACY ON
YOUR SHOW.
VOTE TOMORROW AND VOTE YES ON
THE RECALL.
>> Tucke